total u.s online sports betting will
reach
300 billion dollars by 2030 so that's
just in 10 years seeing a massive jump
hi i'm edward white and this is deep
coverage presented by quick take and the
athletic
online sports betting is big business
and on a meteoric rise
draftkings went public in april through
a reverse
merger that allowed them to be publicly
traded and it's been nothing but games
for investors it's really been
kind of shooting straight up i think
you'll be seeing a lot of people
kind of be okay with gambling because
there's so much money coming in from tax
i mean you saw it in colorado
uh when they legalized marijuana i think
like eight months in they're like
we got enough tax money for the year
like we could stop now so in gambling
you're gonna see the same thing there's
just
the way these laws were passed in each
individual state it really tends to make
a lot of money
for the state the covet 19 pandemic is
also linked to the increase in
popularity of legalized sports betting
online
people are bored people are looking for
entertainment it makes sports a little
more enjoyable and especially now and
we've just kind of been sitting around
and you're waiting for something fun you
can do it a dollar at a time
enjoy it and i think that's that's how
it's going to work it's people are going
to see it it's going to get bigger and
bigger
and just make more money for a lot of
states 22 states have legalized betting
18 allow in-person wagers and 11 allow
for online bets
so it may be a while before the entire
us gets on board
joining me to talk about fantasy sports
and online sports gambling in the us
is managing editor of fantasy for the
athletic fernando de fino
so uh give us a general primer on the
field uh what's the difference between
daily fantasy sports and traditional
sports betting you know how do daily
fantasy and traditional fantasy differ
and then
also how do each of those different
markets compare uh well it's it's it's
kind of interesting the studies that we
used to do with the uh
they still do with the fsga um there's
there's a great overlap between the two
groups uh if you
if you like to sports gamble you
generally also like to play dfs
um the traditional fantasy gamer is a
little different it's more of a
long-term thing you do with friends
but the dfs and the fantasy the fantasy
gaming
groups overlap really nicely uh it's
it's
a burgeoning group they have a lot of
disposable income they've gone to a lot
of schooling
uh it's it's just a very kind of target
rich environment as they would have said
in top gun
uh but it's generally you know people
who are really into sports they're super
fans
there's a little cross-section of people
who just you know very analytical
uh aren't exactly fans but they found a
way to kind of beat the system
uh but it's it's generally a good group
of people uh who
who you know if you want to advertise to
them or if you want to reach them for
your products
they're young they have a lot of money
and they're really into sports
that's a great point um that they are
very target rich
um you know companies like draftkings
and fanduel are
doing a lot of advertising around
sporting sporting events such as you
know
nfl nba playoffs in the bubble mlb
soccer all those different kinds of
sports how have these companies
um sort of legit legitimized the sports
gaming
industry in your opinion nando oh it's
actually been great
there are so many like each state has
their own set of laws but they're all
kind of these
these similar i guess characteristics to
them that
every company has to hit and so if you
know you've got to spend a lot of money
you gotta get all these licenses you've
got to jump through so many hoops
and it's a fairly difficult process
where before if you want to if you want
to gamble on sports
three years ago you know you would go to
las vegas that'd be your only option
unless you want to go online and try one
of these offshore sites
which you know like i i've done them
before and it's just kind of like
you got to send them a copy of your
license you got to go through these 14
different things and they kind of do
whatever they can
to not give you your money but sports
like
draftkings fanduel uh william hill
all these companies that are legitimized
in the united states
are really like you you really really
have to watch what you do
and you have to be super careful or take
it away from you so it just it gives you
a better feeling uh
of confidence and a little more comfort
if you want to use these sites because
they've gone through just
so much and like just all these
different steps they had to complete
in order to be legitimately recognized
in the united states
absolutely absolutely and you mentioned
las vegas as kind of um
one of the first places to have this
kind of sports gambling and you know
it's going to be
sort of spreading out across the u.s so
far new jersey and a bunch of other
states have
have legalized it what effect do you see
this having
on the leagues and the teams and then on
the players
well you know it's in a way it's good
for everybody i mean before
you would see sports gambling kind of in
the shadows and it was a bit of a taboo
subject
but now that it's kind of like out there
um it's it's like
i could i'm on my phone at my in-laws
house talking about you know betting on
the giants game right now
and it's okay like it's totally cool i'm
not like that degenerate anymore
and uh it's it's it's i don't know it's
a good thing for the leagues because
if there's more revenue you know they
may take a little piece of it but
there's a little more exposure for them
there's going to be more interest it
started with fantasy sports like why
would a guy in new york want to watch a
cincinnati bengals game if they're not
playing the giants of the jets or the
bills
and it's because you had a couple guys
on that team now the same thing
and you got you got an interest in the
cincinnati bengals game if you're living
in new york where you might not have
otherwise because you like the line
and you've got a little money on the
game so it really sparks a lot more
interest in everything
you mentioned sort of the new culture
around fantasy sports and around sports
gambling
what do you think this has how do you
think this has affected
the the way that we we think about
sports as a business
is there any sort of new tilt that that
fantasy sports and sports gambling have
made in sports business
so i'm not sure it's happened yet um but
i think as you see more states
ratify it and it becomes legal in more
states there's just
the states that have done it so far
especially new jersey have seen such a
huge windfall
of money coming in and that's tax money
and uh you know
you hear people complain about how uh
you know our municipality had to pay for
the stadium
well now i mean you know maybe it'll be
the draftkings stadium yeah they have
enough money
to basically just take away that whole
taxpayer-funded stadium stuff that
everyone gets so angry about
i think you'll be seeing a lot of that
in the years to come i think you'll be
seeing a lot of people
kind of be okay with gambling because
there's so much money coming in from tax
i mean
you saw it in colorado uh when they
legalized marijuana i think like eight
months in they're like we got enough tax
money for the year like we could stop
now
so in gambling you're gonna see the same
thing there's just the way these laws
were passed in each individual state
it really tends to make a lot of money
for the state
and you know that that's gonna make
people i guess in a way happy if you
really follow that kind of stuff you
might not see it in your everyday life
but
you're gonna get extra money coming into
the coffers and that's because of sports
gambling
and that's usually a good thing that'll
make everybody happy so i think you're
gonna see it reviewed a little more
positively in terms of sports business
because it's basically just making money
for everybody gotcha
and that's that's a great point that
it's sort of um coming to a tipping
point in the us
while it's been legal and accessible in
europe for so long why do you think the
us is just coming around to sports
gambling in such a piecemeal fashion
you know it's i'm not there there's a
there's a faction of people who are
you know anti-gambling you're always
going to hear that story about you know
that
47 year old father who gambled away his
kids college fund and stuff like that
and those i mean those are very
effective stories
uh we haven't actually seen very many of
them yet but i also think maybe you know
it was always just vegas
you know like vegas was where you would
go vegas you know you'd go you'd get
entertained you'd be able to sports
gambling casino gamble stuff like that
but i think as more native american
casinos are opening up and they're
becoming a lot of
especially new york state they're
getting a sportsbook edge to it um
people i think it just took a while to
get it a little bit conditioned to like
oh yeah this you know
having having the turning stone casino
here uh you know right outside of utica
it's not something that's ruined
our city this has actually been pretty
good for it there are new jobs we can go
there for the weekend and hang out in
the hotel
they're doing it very you know these are
these are good things i mean yeah
there's there's a downside to everything
but i think the experience people have
had with a lot of these native american
casinos opening up
is this is actually good for our
community and uh we're not you know
we're not really seeing the cd downside
just yet so
i think they're more open to expanding
that especially if they're hearing that
it's gonna be making more money tax-wise
for everybody agreed
wholeheartedly and uh being in new york
i'm from from mount vernon new york and
um
up in yonkers you know the racetrack up
there george washington
exactly the new the new casino is is
supposedly doing
great numbers um you mentioned jersey
i want to talk about jersey just a
little bit again what's what's bridge
culture like
having to go from new york over the
george washington bridge to go place
bets
what can you talk about with regards to
that uh well i don't think you know i
don't think people
i think it's kind of fun it's like a
little adventure like before you had to
jump on a plane
i mean you could have gone to atlantic
city but you couldn't sports bet in
atlantic city
so i mean you you go across the bridge
you can take the ferry
right to jersey hop on your phone fiddly
boop and then just get right back on and
go back i think it's kind of a
it's like a fun event it's like going to
a pumpkin patch you know like it's if
you're in new york there's no pumpkin
patch by you got to pick it up out of
the box on the sidewalk
this is like i'm going somewhere that's
kind of fun that's close enough
and i'm gonna have a little fun for a
little while if you believe the numbers
like usually it's 19
of people aged 18 plus in the united
states uh
are gamblers or sports bettors and also
daily fantasy players
so i mean you say in the biggest number
700
000 people want to do it say you get
like even 20 000 people coming from new
york in new jersey
just to place a sports bet once in a
while speaking a little bit more about
casinos
the the recent espn draftking and
caesars deal
how significant was that to like the
entire sports gambling and fantasy
sports market
uh it's pretty huge actually i mean
espn's like you know the name
yeah i'm sorry and they can hit you so
many ways like tv
on your phone over the internet uh
streaming on espn plus
so for draftkings being i mean we talked
about i'll put i'll give you a good
example like five years ago
when we're writing stories and uh you
know for for daily fantasy stuff you
want to talk about how good a pitcher is
going to do you talk about the vegas
line
it was always the vegas line is this and
the vegas line is that because that was
the parlance
now you're talking about well draftkings
has them at this
or draftkings has them at that odds and
you know in your head when everyone's
saying the vegas line you're like vegas
now everyone on espn writing about it
it's going to say draftkings has them at
250 draftkings has them here draftkings
has them there
and it just becomes the natural way to
spell out what the odds are so
i think it's it's literally going to
change the conversation and the way you
talk about odds
and with so many people who watch espn
listen to him on the radio have their
podcasts whatever
they're going to hear draftkings has him
at this draftkings has him at that
uh where it used to be you know vegas
says this or you know or fanduel says
this you're just going to hear
draftkings so much that it's just going
to be that automatic place you want to
go to
question can you this is completely
scoopy what's the next big deal to drop
if there is one you know what i so
there's a company called monkey knife
fight that's
been quietly their name fs game then the
gambling but they're they're quietly
like getting partnerships with a lot of
baseball teams
and they're i mean i mean it has been
quiet if you've been following it but
you
the person watching this may never have
heard of monkey knife fight but they're
making some very smart moves
uh on a bigger picture i think bar stool
is just gonna blow it up and i mean like
so many people follow bar stool
and so many people are so loyal to bar
stool that you know
they're gonna have barstool casinos i
think they can brand so many things bar
stool so i'd say monkey knife fight is
gonna be surprisingly big soon
and catch you off guard maybe but
barstool when they're ready to make
their moves man they're going to be
everywhere and they're going to i think
they're going to be the challenger to
draft games
and just piggybacking off what you said
about kind of you know sports gambling
culture
they have their own culture that they
can sort of imprint into whatever they
do which is perfect for them and
sort of puts them in a lead position to
to make big moves like you said
that's exactly what it is yeah um nando
what else should we know about the
sports betting and fantasy sports
industry going forward
um you know we're in the middle of the
the nfl season now
nba playoffs are sort of rounding out
since mlb playoffs are starting to
surround into form
what should we look for going forward uh
well you know fantasy football is always
going to be strong uh that's
like the biggest of them all i think
fantasy baseball this year because it
was a 60 game season this is a very
interesting thing
a lot of people said they enjoyed the
shortened season usually a lot of people
don't play fantasy baseball because it's
a huge slog
uh you know 162 games you gotta know
every single player but this year with
just like a tiny
window i think maybe we'll be seeing
more games just giving people the option
to play just 60 days
instead of the entire season which could
boost that in popularity
uh sports gambling i mean i think there
are about 20 states right now that have
laws that allow it
not all of them are taking bets yet
there's still some things they have to
do
but that's just gonna grow and grow i
mean like maybe you'll get six or seven
states if you just follow the example of
what happened with dfs
and the states that legalize that there
are like six seven states that were
always sticklers
louisiana was one they actually just
came back and brought dfs in and
legalized it which was huge for the
for the industry but i think you see
gambling go the same way just slowly as
everyone sees how much money every
state's making
and especially now with so much money
missing from budgets for
all you know all kinds of things because
of covid uh you're going to see gambling
expand and i think mobile
on the like the fsga is big pushes it
should be on the phone it's got to be on
the phone
that's going to give you more tax money
more widespread people
enjoying sports betting um i don't want
to sound like
you know like a lobbyist for sports
gambling here but it's just
you know you could set your own rules
you can have fun with it it really
sparks interest more in sports in
general because
again you're watching a cincinnati
bengals game for no reason other than
you have
you know three dollars on the bengals to
win or three dollars on joe burrow
to throw more than 280.5 yards uh
it just it makes sports a little more
enjoyable and especially now and we've
just kind of been sitting around and
you're waiting for something fun um you
could do i mean you could do it a dollar
at a time
enjoy it and i think that's that's how
it's going to work it's people are going
to see it it's going to get bigger and
bigger
and just make more money for a lot of
states that's awesome and that's a great
place to end it we learned so much today
nando de fino from the athletic thank
you so much for joining us on deep
coverage